welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the two post-credits
scenes shown at the end of Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania as is always the
case with Marvel movies the audience is
treated to a tease of the future if they
hang around until the end and there's a
lot to talk about as we go into phase
five if you enjoy the video please hit
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe to the channel to join the
Council of kangsters that the heavy
spoilers show now is without the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the post-credits scene
the first one I want to talk about is
actually the second Stinger that we get
in the movie this is taken from Loki
season 2 and it gives us a fair idea of
what the upcoming show is going to be
about Marvel have done this sort of
thing a couple of times before and no
way home of course ended with a trailer
for Multiverse of Madness if we go back
to the first Batman movie that even
ended with a scene from Civil War so
they're very much keeping up tradition
here a Loki season one of course any
with the reveal that the variants of
Nathaniel Richards were now Unleashed
across the Multiverse but the scene from
season two we catch lokia Mobius in a
theater during one of the things the
early 20th century judging by the
clothing here it looks like this is set
between then and roughly the 1920s
either way it's clear that this season
will be doing lots of time travel it's
how we at the channel make video so fast
and now likely using it to track down
variants of Kang across the entire
Multiverse season one was about chasing
down a Loki Varian and I like how this
theme is carried across the the second
season and the variant we catch here is
Victor timely and this in itself is an
Easter egg timely is well to do with
time but before Marvel became Marvel it
was actually a company called timely
Comics that was founded in 1939 the name
then changed to Atlas Comics and it was
during the 60s that it finally became
Marvel still though you can't forget
where you came from and the creators
gave this name to Kang as a kind of meta
joke for Comic readers and the story
Kang ended up suffering a humiliating
defeat and he traveled back to 1901
which is where he created the town
timely under the name Victor timely he
established a community there and not
only did he become the mayor but he also
founded time the industries this had a
range of factories mines and places that
provided him a small fortune he of
course also used his knowledge of future
technology to create highly Advanced
things that shouldn't have existed back
in the era Marvel actually wrecked on
the origin story for the original Human
Torch who was an Android instead of
being the Johnny stormino in love I'm
sure I'm sure I recognize him from
somewhere but yeah this guy wasn't the
original Human Torch now Marvel actually
did an Easter egg for this all the way
back in the first Captain America movie
and at the Expo we could catch a play on
the original Human Torch in attack Chris
Evans of course played the character and
like I tell you every week it's okay
anyway timely also created several of
the Androids including ones of himself
so he could disappear for some time and
do things without rousing suspicion and
not really aging would of course also
raise some eyebrows and just in the same
way that Kingo had to keep making his
death Victor timely also had to die too
Kang then became Victor timely Junior
and he continued the actions under his
new name in this scene he has his
classic mustache and Loki instantly
recognizes him and looks absolutely
terrified Mobius finds him a bit
laughable though and a very much cements
his unassuming figure that we saw with
he who remains I think the sense that
the season's basically gonna be a sort
of buddy cop team up thing where they're
going timeline to timeline and finding
all different kinds of kangs I was
talking to Canadian lad about the scene
and he said he thinks larki will be
trying to find the version that becomes
he who remains which I think is such a
cool idea I don't want to just run off
with the guy's Theory as I'm sure he's
making a video on it so definitely check
us out if you haven't seen it it's a
pretty cool concept and what I love
about the idea of Kang is that you never
know what you're gonna get you could get
a humorous magician or come across a
version that's an evil conqueror there's
also the fact that there are multiple
versions of Kang that have already
formed his castle and that takes us into
the first post-credits scene we see now
in it we see different versions of the
character collected together and we
catch them discussing how the Kang Exile
has been killed this is the version that
we meet in quantumania and though there
is the possibility that he's still alive
they at the very least believe that he's
dead he may have been Darren crossed
into a smaller part of the quantum realm
but either way it shows that not all
kangs are created equal and that's some
are more important and dangerous than
others the council is three key members
who will discuss in just a bit but
they've about to stop the heroes who've
started to meddle with the Multiverse
they say they could destroy everything
they've built and this is of course
referring to the interconnected
timelines that now exist across all
reality he who remains kept things
simple and contained it all to one
timeline because he knew things would
eventually evolve into a giant
multiversal War thus he started prune
timelines until all that was left was
the sacred one that we see appearing in
the first season of Loki Barry and Zach
created Nexus points were pruned but his
death nullified his master plan and now
the Kang's all rule over everything the
Kang sent call for support from the
others and we see that there's a giant
Arena of them including a scroll version
this shot looks similar to their first
appearance in Avengers 292 in which we
got an angle similar to this there are
some that warp in using the same
teleportation that Reed Richards had in
the Multiverse of Madness and the
character is of course a descendant of
him the main variants leading the
council are immortus ramatut and someone
who according to the reports is the
Scarlet Centurion they do look slightly
different but that's what the leaks on
the scene said and as they were pretty
accurate we'll just go with that if you
cast your mind back to Moon Knight you
might also remember that there was a
rama to Easter egg in there and as I've
been saying
in the comics we actually had something
known as the trio of kangs and this
group clearly represent that now Maurice
is one of the most important versions of
Kang and he who remains resulted to look
more in line with him originally in the
comics he who remains was an elderly
being that ended up being the last
leader of the TVA he would stare at the
end of a timeline before things started
up again and he'd leave behind
information so that the next ones could
start things up this cycle went on for
trillions and trillions of years and it
was very much a natural part of the
universe in the MCU he's also the leader
of the TVA but with him being a Kang
variant he has ties to the character too
he who remains wore long purple robes
like our Morris does and purples
actually a color that's associated with
royalty back in the olden days a bit of
a trivia tangent attention it was hard
to die close that color and therefore
only the rich could afford the color
purple anyway immortus is actually one
of the oldest versions of Kang and most
that live long enough to reach that
point usually end up becoming him the
Morris is a sort of of anti-hero who's
even fought alongside the Avengers at
points and a lot of time he finds his
younger self a bit cringy imagine going
back in time and reading a Facebook post
from 10 years ago or watching an old
video where you came up with trivia
tangent engine you just find it
embarrassing and you'd cringe a bit
watching it back now the car makes him
Morris and Kang are being locked in an
almost Everlasting battle and this
actually played out in the Avengers
forever storyline immortus being here
could hint at the way things are going
and we'll give our theories on that in
just a bit and the next character I want
to talk about is ramatut when Nathaniel
Richards first travel through time he
actually went back to ancient Egypt
which is where he'd done the mantle of a
pharaoh traveling through the time
stream on a giant Sphinx he became a
ferocious ruler due to his knowledge of
technology and science we actually got
it onto this vessel in Loki episode 5 as
we did see a sphinx with its nose intact
which looked identical to kangs it's
possible at the void here actually had
several remnants belonging to prune
timelines involved which is why we saw
the king building and the yellowjacket
helmet he of course ended up becoming
Modoc and it may tie back to that
episode in Loki anyway ramita was
defeated by The Fantastic Four who were
displaced in time and this was one of
Kang's first major defeats we of course
know a Fantastic Four film is coming and
potentially they might have ramita as
the antagonist in that tying this all
together now lastly is the Scarlet
Centurion who kind of builds off the
back of ramatut in the comics Kang ended
up being beaten by The Fantastic Four
and he then traveled to the 20th century
which is where he came across Dr Doom
believing they were relatives they
started to work together and Kang became
the Scarlet Centurion he created armor
based on Doom's designs and they may end
up bringing this into the MCU Doom
hasn't been introduced yet but they
could very much have Kang somewhat
creating the character after meeting him
and forging a path for him to become a
super villain the Centurion was beaten
by The Avengers and after this defeat he
aimed to travel to the 31st Century you
have a shot though and he ended up on a
world decimated by War now in regards to
what could be happening here if we look
at the comics there are some Clues over
time a version of Kang rose up called
Prime Kang Who start eliminating
timelines at the other versions of Kang
came from this annoyed some of them
started some infighting and basically
led to the Avengers stopping Kang whilst
he had all this other stuff to deal with
it built to a battle between prime Kang
and the last other remaining Kang and
that one died when trying to kill Prime
as the weapon he used backfired on him
this left Prime Kang is seemingly the
last one on the console however there
was an extra twist it turned out that
immorus was actually manipulating the
entire thing and that he'd created the
council to bring everyone together to
destroy them he also created something
known as the cycler which brought
together the memories of every different
version of Kang that had ever existed
with his knowledge immortus intended to
become the ruler of all time and I think
this might be something that's brought
across to the MCU and the scroll version
is really interesting testing 2 as we
have secret Invasion coming out in a
couple of months potentially we'll see
this variant of Kang in that series
though this might be something that they
don't end up including either way I
think there's big things going to be
happening with the character going
forward into the future yeah no
either way with Jonathan Majors being
the best part of the movie by far I
can't wait to see what they cook up the
Council of kangs has influenced several
things such as the council Rex from Rick
and Morty and Reed Richards even had to
create his own Council in order to try
and beat them lots of things that could
happen and let me know your thoughts
below and where you think they're going
to take things we are in a competition
right now and giving away the rocky 4K
box set to 3 subscribers on the 15th of
March and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie we
picked the comments out random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on Twitter
heavy spoilers you want to be else to
watch them make sure you check out one
of our trailer breakdowns on screen
right now got Guardians of the Galaxy 3
what else do you want me join the flash
I've got that too so definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for clicking the video I've been
poor and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]